hey fans I'm Liana Galera and I'm joined
by my three favorite ladies the stars of
the bold type of chair good morning
happy premier day thank you season three
is finally here Katie
Megan Asia I'm so glad that you could
join us today let's talk about season
three let's talk about it I know that
there are some things you can say some
things you can't say we're gonna be
playing a little game today we're gonna
be taking your fan questions to start
sending them in to us but when you look
at season three as a whole how do you
think it compares or differs to the
first two seasons I mean I feel like an
I feel like we've been just like
progressively watching the girls grow up
right so like in the first season they
were kind of trying to figure out what
it is they wanted and then in the second
season they were asking for what they
wanted and now in the third season I
think they're just like dealing with
what that means when you ask for what
you want you finally like yeah and I
feel like we're also gonna start seeing
these friendships strengthen even more
as they come into I don't know kind of
looking at the new hurdles that are
coming their way particularly with these
two lovely roomies right now what can
you tease about what's coming up for
them I'm wondering what's already been
teased I mean the first episode we do
see Sutton Richard asks Sutton to move
in with him so that's a big deal because
Jane and sudden have been living
together for a while and you know I
think that that's like an interesting
thing to show navigating because there
is kind of a time where you kind of stop
having like sleepovers with your friends
because you've like found your person
and like that's who you spend every
night with and you know so I think that
that's an interesting thing in
friendship to kind of navigate is like
when you start moving into a more
serious relationship kind of place in
your life where does that put your
friendships yeah how do you balance both
they also don't like sharing your space
because cats just got her own gorgeous
apartment yeah I get it like there's a
moment where in a later episode it seems
like do you guys live together and cats
like god no and I felt that she really
does like to have her own space yeah
she's gonna like charge she's gonna like
get married one day but like her and her
person are gonna have a separate like
separate bedroom no I do like to cuddle
but like cuddle and then go to your room
but like if I'm if I'm PMSing like I
want you gone yes yeah sorry not sorry
well your person's gonna know that or
they um I love the friendships of course
on the bolt I've seen the three of you
ladies evolve on screen and also bond
off-screen has been so fun for fans to
watch what is something that you can
tease about their dynamic as they move
forward in season 3 and are we gonna see
these friendships you test it a little
bit more this year we've got quite a bit
last season I mean I think that what you
see without fail is the girls are always
there for each other through thick and
thin like through any situation you're
going to see them there for Sutton as
she makes this transition you're gonna
see that them they're for Jane they're
for cat in a pretty big moment of her
life so I think that it's just kind of
continuing to show that friendship and
to show that bond and and show how they
kind of move through the world and
navigate difficult situations but always
maintaining their friendship it's hard
when you're at different points in your
life I think like sometimes when your
friends are in these like serious
relationships and you're like wow I'm
completely alone so I need someone to
like come hang out with me for a second
and what's great about I think even just
in the first episode we see Jane and
Sutton really like they're there for Kat
through that and I think sometimes that
can cause a rift in your friendships
when you're just at different points in
your life like you know your friends are
like getting married having babies and
stuff but it's possible Wow like it's so
that's like that's like a challenge that
you have to overcome as friends and
they're the ones who were there
you know for your life anyway they're
your soul mate I think um I want to tell
the fans right now that we get to see
finally Sutton and Richard in a
full-fledged relationship and it's so
wonderful to see they're so cute
together
what was it like for you to finally get
to play this amazing I think you know
the first two seasons were very well
they won't they it's very secretive and
I think it's it's so fun to see them
enjoying each other I mean granted there
are a lot of obstacles that they have to
face I think back to what Asia said
which is like now Sutton has said this
is what I want it's to be in this
relationship with you and a public and
then we have to see them sort of deal
with the consequences of that so it's
not without complications but it is
really lovely to like you know see them
go out to dinner together mm-hmm just
talk about like Oh cute yeah it was
certainly fun I think there's one scene
in episode 3 where you guys are like
discussing what his nickname is or
something that like so he wrote me
watching it it's so cute it's very cute
Sam page is the most amazing scene
partner so I was so happy to get to do
her some work with him cuz he's so
talented very symmetrical man and
handsome but also very talented too all
right Sam I feel like it was just
objectifying you you're a beautiful man
is I don't know Katie what can you tease
about James love life obviously you left
us on big cliffhanger and fans are
finally gonna get that answer I will I
[Laughter]
will tease that tease I will tease that
it's sexy oh I will tease that Jane is
happy with the decision that she's made
and so am i when Megan in my life yeah
yeah and that it's like it's it's really
cute to see Jane finally in relationship
as well and seeing how she kind of
navigates that you'll see her she I
think she had difficulty last season
with kind of letting anybody in on what
she was going through medically and
you're gonna
see her let this person in with some
complications before but yeah I love
that too
I love seeing like a young person deal
with medical stuff you know you have to
see that like we all have to go to
doctors and stuff and it's
time-consuming and it's weird and like
fertility issues are such a real thing
yeah I love getting yeah it's taught me
it's taught me a lot in terms of like
when I go to my doctor's like asking the
right questions in terms of like being a
female and having to deal with whatever
your life plan is gonna be and you know
your fertility or like just hormonal II
what goes on in a woman but getting to
like play Jane through this experience
has given me a lot of information has
given me a lot of confidence to like go
to my doctors and like ask questions and
not be afraid of what the answers are
because the answers are just information
and once you have the information that's
like you're an advocate like knowledge
is power so I've got a couple of random
questions for you guys that I know that
you all have who has the most risque
scene in season three I want to say Katy
and I don't even know if that's true
it's just like what comes to mind I
think of it I do it's almost always can
wait yeah it might not like I mean I'm
just let's just be real I'm always
having sex on the show Oh waiter
always and Janes the one who's been
needing to like explore the most yeah so
there is an episode coming up if they
believe it's episode three where Jane is
doing some exploring with her new
partner and I have a scene that I want
to say I felt hotter than I've ever felt
wearing a certain certain thing and you
like I never one to pay myself a
compliment I'm normally like really
insecure but I'm like it was a blanket
[Laughter]
the most like awkward storyline since
season three like when you were playing
it out you're just like oh god
not me really probably how are you or
you know it's not me uh I say probably I
eater episode yeah yeah sure man yeah I
don't know how to say stuff I don't know
what I'm allowed to say you can tell me
everything and then a man oh this
freaked out or in the car um who has the
most pinch me I can't believe this is
happening to me a moment because I
thought it was in the first episode when
we see you guys have a private Betty who
concert oh yeah I think show is full of
those moments yeah we yeah there's wish
fulfillment my life's not like that
you know I was showing I'm like oh my
god this is such a cool life I wish I
had Megan's like my life it was like
Betty who performs in my backyard
concert for one yeah I would say so and
has a pretty big one in the finale
Oh
[Music]
rewind the truth is that Sutton does
have a really magical moment at the end
of the season yeah which I forgot about
which is is really exciting and and and
I'm yeah you get to see all the girls
thrive this season yes I love um we're
gonna play a little game right now
ooh I love games and this game is called
bold or by II which one do you drink on
Boulder buy so actually yes you drink on
both um but so I'm gonna give you some
scenarios some of which are inspired by
the season three storylines so look out
for that guys and you tell me bold if
you're all here for it or by II if
you're not a fan okay so a significant
other who likes to walk around Nicki
even though you have roommates bold I
think walking around naked is absolutely
on your vomit it is
absolutely something you must do love it
posting a sultry pic on Instagram
because you know your ex's new boo will
see it bold oh love it yeah fan that
Instagram trash hole like I love a story
that is posted for one person I am so
here that you compose stories on one
person also
why can't you so choose looking at the
story you can you should be able to
that's that's the best things you can I
call me is like like I can see how do
you do that I can see when my dress is I
can see when my exes have like liked my
photos or like seeing my story and I'm
like yeah so fun hashtag you blew it
good next one
mm-hmm telling off a man for being
skeezy but he's also your boyfriend's
colleague bold wait is he your boyfriend
yeah yeah Oh bold don't forget that guy
yep yeah trash trash uh hooking up with
a co-worker in the office but I can't
cuz I do it on the show I just think
that every time I just think it's like
don't put your life though I probably
probably would say BAE know you would
probably do it where you can life is
short
yeah um spending your entire paycheck on
one item no bye bye bye save your money
yeah I still like I still buy the cheap
toilet oh my gosh yourself but also I'm
like treat yourself but then I look at
my rent you know but my the thing that I
spend the most money on is eating out
cuz I just love food yeah they're so I'm
like treat yourself but like girl you
know how to cook I've also been buying
like alkalizer Asia in my salon risotto
this is this one brand of water
Mountain Valley and say oh whatever
Mountain Valley do you want is fun to me
it's a big green she is so obsessive
that it's so crazy she'll get like a big
bottle of it and drink it she's like
this is the best water I've ever tasted
try it and I drink it I'm like no yes
that's water no this is false people say
that you can you can tell that they can
tell the difference between water and I
put it to the test at my birthday trip
to Big Bear one year I had like tiny you
well I lined up all those waters and no
I know
hold it and lined it up and we had two
of our friends who were both like I
could tell I know what Fiji tastes like
got every single one wrong know what
that weight is yes to line up like a
bunch of beer and somebody's like like
the cheap ones and the expensive ones
and it's an IPA
what's our show called what was the
question last question of the game went
great ready challenging a co-worker
who's not a good fit for the company but
also happens to be your new boss bolt I
want to say bold but like we both it
only bold if you know you won't get
fired yeah we could all get fired but I
think that there is a way to challenge a
person that is like respectful yes I'm
saying that's what I'm saying is if you
do it in a way when I agreeing um we're
about to take it out to the fan
questions in just a little bit but I
want to talk about the flashback episode
oh yeah I am so excited for all you fans
out there you might not know that
there's going there's an entire
flashback episode it's going to show how
these three lovely ladies met
what can you tease about that episode
please just tell us everything
our outfits are special I mean we tried
to do it like what the fashion trends
were for that year but it's not exactly
vintage yeah I think it's like 2014 like
2013 so it
like I think okay right ladies straight
hair I think the flashback opens with
welcome to New York by Taylor Swift
because that was the year that record
came out it was I don't know Rob Lowry
did a really great job of like he's
using music just from that time yeah but
I think like we also did it in a way
that was like campy where we like knew
that it was kind of ridiculous yeah I
like the flashback like like I have
bangs which was actually like a request
because I just wanted Jane to be kind of
like dorky yeah and I and I asked if
they would also give me platform
sneakers because like that was also
something that people probably were like
this is really cute and cooling the
sneakers laughs yeah yeah which like I
also did so I absolutely did that yes
ooh but I need the height I was just I
was given some healed snake isn't free
stuff cat has a pink cat my stuff cat
has pink hair
yeah there's I got some highlights in my
fro which I was like when they put those
in I was like you should yeah that works
I don't know I feel like if I'm gonna do
like pink highlights like I want my
entire fro to be paying yeah you know
yeah I'm ready I'm here for that thing
um I'm also here for all these fan
comments that we're getting right now
some really good ones
Sonia says will there ever be a musical
episode of the bold type we are pushing
for it we can hear you can look wherever
you'd like
hello there hey we're pushing for it but
everyone should just tweet it yes free
foam or tweet it free form Universal all
the people that you want it it was so
great to see you the karaoke moment it's
so good that anytime there's a
microphone Jane's like hi I'm not drunk
anymore it's honestly true to actual
life
yeah we want a musical episode we're
ready Teddy just wanted to say you
ladies look so beautiful today
Thank You Danny
ooh is there any animosity between cat
and Tina like Nicole I love like more
than most things in this entire world is
there any animosity no I don't think so
in my mind I think it's more just like
you know when you're in a relationship
and something ends so fast and it's like
confusing and you're like wait why did
we even break up that made no sense
because some breakups just don't make
sense yeah so you're kind of left it's
just a fight that snowballs
yeah but then and then you're like in
different continents and so you never
really get to like hash it out and have
the fights that you want to have in
order to really
unfortunately I've always been on the
same continent as my ex oh I just go you
just go straight back to Australia oh
I'm out of here for a while
fashion row I just took my time with it
I think is the key and says Katie please
tell us about Jane and Jacqueline
teaming up for an investigative work so
basically I'm excited because we kind of
take on a gray area of the meet -
movement in terms of like I think the me
- movement has been seen as like men
being in a position of abusing power and
we come across somebody who is a woman
in a position abusing power and so Jane
and Jacqueline decide to investigate it
and write about it together like I said
it's my favorite ship of the show I love
seeing them work together same I'm like
make out me
looking I'm joking but like I do but
your ladies all day same can we get
another round I mean I need there's no
more question we have to we have to end
it right now I'm sad but fans can tune
in every Tuesday night on free every
Tuesday night at watch night
yes tweet about it season three tweet
about it we're trying to get more thank
you all so much for joining us today we
had no fun at all thank you bye-bye
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]